اندلعت مواجهات بين السلطه ومحتجين في
باريس لليوم الثاني على التوالي في
مظاهرات شارك فيها سياسيون من اليسار
الفرنسي احتجاجا على مقتل ثلاثه اكراد
واصابه اخرين في هجوم على المركز الثقافي
الكردي وسط العاصمه الفرنسيه يوم الجمعه
وقد كشف مصدر مقرب من التحقيقات ان
المشتبه به في تنفيذ الهجوم اكد انه
ارتكبه لدافع عنصريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه 3 مسارات ما هي السياقات التي وقع
فيها هجوم باريس وما مدى ارتباطه بسعود
اليمين وتعالي الاصوات المعاديه للمهاجرين
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان تاتي مواقف السلطه
والقوه الفرنسيه السياسيه المختلفه من
الهجوم بعد اقرار مرتكبه بالدوافع
العنصريه لتنفيذه وما هي التغييرات التي
يمكن ان يتركها هجوم الجمعه في باريس على
اوضاع المهاجرين والموقف منهم في فرنسا
خاصه وفي اوروبا على وجه العمر
[موسيقى]
على مدى يومين وقعت في العاصمه الفرنسيه
بين الشرطه ومحتاجين اغلبهم اكراد خرجوا
للتمديد بمقتل ثلاثه افراد من الجاريه
الكرديه واصابه اخرين يوم الجمعه
بالارهابي وشددوا على ان دوافعه سياسيه
رفعوا الاعلام الكرديه ولافتات تعبر عن
الغضب من الهجوم ومما سموه التقصير
الامنيه الفرنسيه
خاصه من اليسار الفرنسي بالهجوم الذي ياتي
في ظل صعود اليمين المتشدد وارتفاع
الاصوات المعاديه للمهاجرين
ووافقه ما كشفه مصدر مقرب من التحقيقات في
هجوم باريس فان المشتبه به في تنفيذ
الهجوم اكد انه ارتكب الاعتداء لدوافع
عنصريه واضاف المصدر ان الشرطه عثرت
بحوزته على حقيبه صغيره تضم ذخائر بعضها
معد لاستخدام بينما قالت مصادر امنيه اخرى
ان الرجل لم يصنف على انه من اليمين
والتطرف
وكان القضاء الفرنسي قد حكم على المشتبه
به والذي اظهرت كاميرات مراقبه لحظه
تنفيذه جانبا من الهجوم بالسجن في حزيران
يونيو الماضي بتهمه ارتكاب اعمال عنف
المسلحه عام 2016 كما اتهم في كانون الاول
ديسمبر الماضي بارتكابه اعمال عنف المسلحه
ذات طابع عنصري مع سبق الاصرار وبالتسبب
في اضراره لافعال ارتكبها في الثامن من
الشهر نفسه
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا
رئيس جمعيه عداله وحقوق بلا حدود والمرشح
السابق للانتخابات التشريعيه الفرنسيه ومن
باريس ايضا الباحث الباحث السياسي الدكتور
صلاح القادري اهلا بكم
وفي اي سياره
ياتي هذا الهجوم وكيف يمكن فهمه هل يمكن
ان نقول انه بوضوح في السياق صعود التيار
اليميني المتشدده او المتطرف في فرنسا
بشكل خاص وفي اوروبا بشكل عام
بومبا
الاسر المصابه
وانني افكر بكل هذه الاسر الحزينه واقول
لهم انا جميعا
بلد بحقوق الانسان
هو امر غير مقبول اطلاقا وبالتالي
شديده
وتعاطف مع كل الاسر الضحايا ولكن ايضا
لابد من القائل باننا
نوجه النداء الرسميه
غير المقبول هذا الهجوم العنصريه ولكن ليس
فقط الصوديا بل هو هجوم ارهابي هجوم
اجرامي
واليوم نعرف ان العمل العنصري هو التهمه
يوجهتها الدعاء العام ولكن هذا اللي ينبغي
ان يصير غضبنا لانه نحن اليوم
لدينا تاكيد ومؤكد بان كان هناك شيء ما قد
جرى
بسبب العنصريه وذلك ذلك ان هذا العمل كان
العمل
وبالتالي هنا المصطلحات مهمه جدا فعندما
نتحدث عندما هناك هجوم يقوم به مسلم او
اسلام
فورا اما اليوم فان كل التغطيه الاعلاميه
لا تتحدث
الهجوم ولا عن عمل ارهابي رغم ان هذه
الهجوم
وبالتالي فاليوم لا بد ان نطرح السؤال هل
هناك همم همم
عليك انت فرنسي وتقيم في فرنسا وهذا
بالفعل يبدو محيرا همم جدا للعرب
والمسلمين ما هي محددات ان يكون العمل
ارهابيا انت تقول ولست انا عندما يقوم
بهذا مسلم مباشره يقال ارهابي ما الذي
يحدد ما هو العمل الارهابي وما هو العمل
غير الارهاب في المنطق حتى الذي يتم
الحديث به
نوع الموسيقي الامر واضح جدا في عاده
التوصيف
التوصيف يتعلق وامر ظمن السلطه القضائيه
العامرون ذلك لكن الفرق بين عمل همم
الانتماء
السياسيه مطالون فيها اليوم لم ينتهي
التحقيق والرجل الذي
حاليا فقط
السلطه القضائيه وانا اليوم كمان قلته لدي
ثقه كامله بهذه السلطه القضائيه لدينا لكن
ما يقلقني ليس السلطه القضائيه بل السلطه
او الخطاب الشعبوي سنعود الى موضوع الخطاب
الشعبي
نعم سنعود الى موضوع خطاب الشعبوي ولكن
نشرك السيد همم صلاح القادري
المحتجون يحتجوا ايضا على ما وصفوه بتقصير
السلطات في حمايتهم كيف يمكن للسلطه ان ان
تحميه
مساء الخير سيد الكريم نحن شاهدنا بعد
احداث الثالث عشر من نوفمبر التي كانت
احداث دمويه ارهابيه تمسك التراب الفرنسي
والمواطنين الفرنسيه وكانت اعمار
الارهابيه بشعه راينا كيف تعاملت السلطات
الفرنسيه مع هؤلاء حيث تعاملت في اقل من
48 ساعه 72 ساعه قامت بالدخول الى الى
الاف المنازل ووضعت مئات الاشخاص تحت
المراقبه
القضائيه وقامت كذلك باصدار مذكرات خاصه
ومن نسميه هنا في فرنسا في حق المئات من
الاشخاص ومنعتهم كذلك من التحرك من
منازلهم كاجراءاتهم وقائيه كان هذا العمل
تحت ما يسمى بالارهاب الاسلامي لكن اليوم
الذي قد يغضب بعض المتظاهرين لماذا لا
يتصرف بنفس الطريقه الان هناك شخصيه تتبنى
افكار يمنيه متطرفه وهو في حد ذاته ادلى
بهذا التصريح اثناء التوقيفه حيث قال انا
افعل ذلك
بدوافع عنصريه لكن بالرغم من ذلك ما زال
الكلام كلمه ارهابي وكلمه ارهاب لم لم
تطلق بعد وليست هذه اول عمليه تحصل بين
طرف ال ال ال ال الهوياتيين كمال سميهم
هنا في فرنسا او من انصار اليمين المتطرف
اليوم الذي كان من المحتمل الان ان ان ان
تفوز المغرب على فرنسا مثلا قبض على 40
شخص من اليمين المتطرف كانوا يحملون اسلحه
بيضاء بل اسلحه ناريه قريبين من شارع
الاليزي طيب ما هو لا يعتبر
القبض على هؤلاء ليس هذا نوع من الحمايه
يعني
ان تطالب بان يقفوا اشخاص لم يقوموا
بارتكاب اي جريمه بعد
لا ال ال هؤلاء الذين تم توقيفهم من
الطبيعه ان يتم توقيفهم لانهم يحملون
اسلحه الناريه واسلحه لكن لم يتكلم احد عن
خطر الارهاب اليمين المتطرف لماذا حينما
يخرج احد من ابناء المهاجرين ويقوم بعمليه
اجراميه نقول هذا ارهاب وحينما يكون ال-
ال- المهاجرون وابناء المهاجرين والفرنسيه
من اصول المهاجره هم الضحايا نقول على
انها مجرد عمليه اجراميه ازدواجيه
المعايير في توصيف الاعمال الاجراميه بين
اعمال الاجراميه بسيطه وبين اعمال
الارهابيه هذه اصل المشكله الغضب الموجود
الان في امرين اثنين في توصيف العمليه لحد
الان لم توصيفه على ان عمليه ارهابيه من
طرف المسؤولين الفرنسيين وعلى راس من رئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل حينما قال ان هذا ان هذا
همم الهجوم هو الهجوم المقيط كلمه هجوم
مقيد تطلق حتى على اعتداء على انسان بسيط
في الشارع لماذا لم يسمى هذا الهجوم هجوم
الا هذا هذا هو السؤال سيدي الكريم تفضل
طريقه التعامل مع الشخصيات المتطرفه طريقه
التعامل مع الشخصيات المتطرفه هذا الشخص
لديه ثوابق في سنه 2016 2021 2022 لم
يستعمل الاسلحه الناريه لاول مره لم يعتدي
على المهاجرين لاول مره لم يقوم بعمليات
ذات دوافع عنصريه لاول مره صدر في حقه
متابعه قضائيه صدر في حقه عدم امتلاك
السلاح لمده خمس سنوات لماذا لم يطبق هذه
القرارات القضائيه لماذا لم تطبقها السلطه
التنفيذيه وزاره الداخليه الفرنسيه على
مثل هذا نتخيل الوضع يشارك بين الاخر لو
جاء واحد من ابناء المهاجرين العرب وقام
بالاعتداء في سنه 2016 بسلاح ناري وفي
2021 وفي 2022 وصدر في حكم قضائي هل يتخيل
البعض انه سيتزوج في شوارع باريس وهو يحمل
حقيبه فيها مقارب 50 طلقه ناريه ويحمل
سلاحا انا اؤكد لك انه لن يحدث ذلك ايه ده
سيواجهه المعايير في توصيف العمليه على
انها ارهابيه وليست ارهابيه والتعامل مع
المجرمين على انهم
بتساهل مع البعض وكيف هذا السيد همم
لا اقول مضبوط ومنضبط بشكل قوي جدا هذا هو
الذي يضيء يثير غضب ابناء المهاجرين هناك
همم انت يعني تقول تثق في السلطه القضائيه
ولكن في النهايه النقاط التي تحدث عنها
السيد صلاح القادري في التعامل مع
المتطرفين وازواجيه المعايير همم هذه ليست
خطاب ولكن يبدو انها امر في صلب السلطه
لان انتقاداته همم لان الانتقاداته هي
السلطه وكيفيه تعاملها وكيف انها تتعامل
بمكان العين بشكل واضح وصارخ
نعم نعم انا اشارك واتفق مع معه
والدعوه التي قدمها المتحدث المجاني
الكرديه
بالتاكيد انه عمل الرابي اقول مره اخرى
الدعم هو الذي يقرر هناك فصل بين السلطه
التنفيذيه والسلطه القضائيه لابد ان نحترم
انا امله جميعا ان الدعاء العام سيجدا
الاسباب ويوسف هذا يوصف هذه الهجوم بانه
عمل ارهابي لانه اليه هناك كل عناصر ذلك
هناك الانتماء وهناك
هذه
السياسيه الاجراميه همم هو العنصريه التي
وصلت الى هذا الحد وايضا او مد القول من
ليس فقط اليوم الخطاب الخطاب الشعبوي ولسه
صديق الخطاب السياسي والخطاب الاعلامي يضع
الاجانب يضع يضع المسلمين في المسلمون
وفرنسا على على انهم اجانب وهذا ينبغي ان
يتوقف لانه هذا الخطاب
السياسيوم اليوم هذا خطاب السياسي
والعلامي سيء جدا همم للسلام العام وسلامه
فرنسا وهذا يكشف امورا كثيره هو انني
مقتنع عن رغم كل شيء هذا عمل منعزل ورغم
انه اليوم لدينا شخص كما قال الضيف الاخر
همم
تقريبا
400 شخص بعد مباراه فرنسا
ويتوجه الى العرب
وبالتالي ايه
المسؤولون قاموا بواجبهم والقوا القبض على
او الاشخاص وبعض مقدم القضاء اذا لابد ان
نثق بالعداله طيب طيب سيد صلاح القادري
السيد صلاح القادري ولكن يبدو ان هذه همم
الخطاب الشعبوي الذي بدا بالحديث عنه قبل
قليل
اصبح نقطه تجذب بالنسبه لاساسه هل هذا
دليل على ان هناك تغيرا في المجتمع
الفرنسي نفسه اذا كان السياسي يعتبرون هذا
سوف يجذب ان الناخبين لهم هل هناك مؤشرات
واضحه على ان التغير نحو اليمين المتطرف
موجود بوضوح داخل المجتمع الفرنسي
قبل ان اجيبك على هذه على هذا السؤال
المهم الاستاذ انا دعني فقط اعلق على كلام
سيد يعيش حينما التي يقول بان توصيف العمل
الارهابي هو من حق ال المدعي العام انا لا
اعتقد ذلك بتحدى مبدا الفصل بين السلطات
حدثت اعمال ارهابيه قبل هذه كان المستهدف
منها هم كان المستهدفون والمجرمون هم من
اصول سواء عربيه او اسلاميه ومن اصول
المهاجره الاعلام والمفكرون الفرنسيون
والساسه الفرنسيون والسلطه التنفيذيه في
فرنسا لم تنتظر ان المدعي العام يكمل
التحقيقات لتوصيف هذا العمل بعمل الارهابي
من اول بدايه اول ما سمعوا ان وراء هذه
قالوا انه احد الحاضنين الشهود العيان قال
اني سمعت الذي كان يقتل الناس يقول الله
اكبر انت هذا الموضوع اذا هذا همم لا اظن
ان هذه القضيه هي قضيه صحيحه كان دائما
توصيف الارهاب يطلق من طرف الساسه السلطه
التنفيذيه المفكرون وكذلك ميول من بدايه
العمليه هناك ازدواجيه معايير حاضره بقوه
حينما يكون الضحيه هو الجلاد او المجرم هو
من اصول المهاجره من اصول عربيه واسلاميه
هو ارهابي حينما يكون المجرم ذو عيون
زرقاء بشره البيضاء من اصول يهوديه
المسيحيه ومن اصول الاوروبيه هذه مجرد
وعمليه اجراميه ازدواجيه العامه المعايير
حاضره ولا يمكن التغطيه عليها باي شكل من
الاشكال النقطه الثانيه التي سالتني عليها
سيد الكريم بالنسبه لتغير المجتمع الفرنسي
هذا واضح للعيان حينما نسمع احد المرشحين
للرئاسه الذي كان مرشحا ان يصبح رئيسا
لفرنسا
يقول بان قصه حتى القصر والقاصرين من
ابناء المهاجرين هم نصوصا
وهمم وهم مغتصبون وهم كذلك مجرمون وهذا
الرجل الذي الذي اسمه قام القضاء الفرنسي
في همم
باصدار احكام قضائيه بانه يدعو الى
التحريض وانه يدعو الى الى الى شتم والى
كذلك الاستنقاص بناء العرب والمسلمين
والتحريض على اساس ديني وعرقي بالرغم من
ذلك ثلاث احكام قضائيه لكنه وجد نفسه
مرشحا لرئاسه الفرنسيه الاكثر من ذلك
حينما يتفتح شركه مثل كنال بريوس او شركه
قناه مثل سينيوس تعطي في قمه الذروه
الاعلاميه في المساء تعطي لهذا الرجل
ساعتين وهو يملا رؤوس الفرنسيه
مشاعرهم ضد المهاجرين والعرب ولا يتكلم
احد هناك تغير في المجتمع الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
انقلاب ومن كان يمكن ان يتخيل ذلك
في المانيا ويحدث ما يحدث الان في فرنسا
الا يستدعي ذلك موقفا من هذا اليمين
المتشدد والمتطرف حتى لا تذهب الامور في
منحا لا يحمد عقبان
وليس من مصلحه كما كنت انت تقول قبل قليل
سلام هذه المجتمعات
كما نحن نعيش في بلدين وفيه دستور هناك
قانون
وانني اقول
لهم توجه الى القضاء الى العداله فكل
الرمايه يخرج سياسي عن الطريق وكل ما يقول
السياسي شيئا سيء لابد من التوجه الى
المحاكم ورفع الدعوه القضائيه
وصدقون النظام القضائي في فرنسا نظام همم
100%
ويجيب على كل هذه انواع المواضيع وفعلا
لابد ان نميز بين الخطاب السياسي والخطاب
القضائي
الخطاب السياسي هو الخطاب مع الاسف اليوم
همم
الى السكان المسلمين وكل الاجانب ويضع
الامن
هو ان يكون يعني يدعى في حده يقف عند حده
في الواقع ما الذي ما العمل نعم لابد من
التوجه الى القضاء
لا يروننا الدستورنا قوي ولابد الاجانب
الاجانب ان يستطيعوا ان ينشروا ان يتحركوا
ان يبينوا الصوره الحقيقيه للاجنبي هو
لابد للمسلمين فرنسا ان يكونوا ناشطين
فاعلين اقوياء ليبينوا ما هو الوجه
الحقيقي
يتناسب اطلاقا مع وجه الاجانب المسلمين في
فرنسا شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكما من باريس
عداله وحقوق بلا حدود والمرشح السابق
بالانتخابات التشريعيه للانتخابات
التشريعيه الفرنسيه ايضا الباحث السياسي
الدكتور صلاح القادري شكرا جزيلا لكم
والى هناك تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم على المتابعه والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]